yeah hello and welcome to the city of
playing black hard to be again I played
him two games ago and back then we had
an e-form opening held hyper hyper
accelerated to Dragon right and now I'm
going to play something different ideas
383 that leads to interesting plane why
does not go in d4 all that quickly as a
couple of implications one is that not
having played d4 you sometimes can feel
keto with b3 Bishop b2 and bishops
diagonal still open and you are a little
bit quicker on the queenside like
hereafter in particular this move let's
see what he does now okay he actually
allows us now I have played typical
moves for the Slav defense but I haven't
played d4 and the funny thing is that
yeah he has a hard time now to to cover
all this and we should pay three I
wonder can I go to kinetic on b7 I
really wonder about this Queen b7 like
d4 I said move d4 Queen takes f3 takes
on c3 etiqueta that that just wins wins
the exchange
what is he able to somehow trap McQueen
if I take on b7 I don't really know why
I cannot hear mom I don't see why I
cannot take it maybe there is a reason
now it's that blitz chess for 480
actually that's a good question did I
did I change the number I think it's for
481 right for 481 think this is correct
yeah yeah for 481 that's right
okay now of course I have to do it
beforehand
oh not afterwards okay so he basically
agrees that I could have played Queen
takes b7 I hope I was right in that
assumption and not did Stern I didn't do
some some nonsense calculation there so
I am a pawn up yeah e6 looks very normal
d5 is attacked so and I will take that
pawn replace something known forcing
yeah maybe he's very dead after he 695
that's going to be an immediate problem
okay but okay I'm quite happy with an
endgame but what about Bishop to a6 just
asking what about this if he takes it
Bishop takes I'm going to win d5 again
and I'm threatening the Queen
20 xb7 Bishop e7 Ruby 8 Bishop takes d5
is the second prong yeah one point again
of this setup is that I'm kind of didn't
play d4 and this is quite a quite a nice
tempo in a way of to to save okay um I
can again play Bishop b7 and take that
pawn I can also play Bishop b5 check and
force him to play King to d8 so it looks
quite nice but the second pawn the
winning a second point is very tempting
I wonder if I should flick in this check
I think I should he has to play the King
now 97 looks very weird I don't know
maybe maybe it is in comparison even the
better choice now but it is some sort of
concession I can't take with the night
actually this is interesting if I take
with the night he cannot attack my
Bishop which would be a problem and he
has no wood square for this night to go
to so then I take with the night not
even giving him the bishop pair or let's
say I'm not conceding my bishop pair
that I have on top of the two extra
pawns
yeah see who I am b3 maybe him anyway it
doesn't really matter but two points
okay he wants to play Bishop g7 to put
some pressure on the b2 porn
I have d4 though finally let's move the
center
yeah with hindsight I know Bishop c4 was
that great maybe I should have gone to
b3 immediately not a big deal of it
I'm just stopping e5 him so that the
bishop looks does not I mean looks
passive at is passive okay well a force
not really threatening I can just take
that point if he plays it okay it's
there no no pen when it is a pen but you
cannot attack the d2 bishop
okay the airport should do the trick if
I take rook b1 rook a to look b7 check
hmm anyway I mean I can't push the still
got two of them
yeah Bishop e5 now should win no it
doesn't win material actually Bishop b5
checking IP five rupee to Knight takes
d4 check pawn takes rook takes b2 a7 and
at the end I win I promote okay yeah
and touchdown
yeah okay that was second guineans
Blackheart let's have a look at the
analysis Bowden was a bit of an opening
disaster for black let's see how that
happened we had this um not very active
looking opening but it is not bad I mean
really not so what six and yeah Bishop
g4 this is not terrible that you have to
be I think quite precise against it I
think like you should take on f3 this is
what I know that that black is normally
doing and then you have this choice
between taking with the pawn or taking
with the Queen this in fact is only a
slight advantage for white as far as I
know yeah and now we had Queen b3 and he
took on f3 and early I think I can take
on b7 yeah the engine agrees at least on
this is this depth will be seven night
be g7 Quincy idea Bishop s6 is an
annoying move for him and here there are
multiple ways of being better but this
was I think okay it's just two points
for for nothing basically yeah right
here yeah I think it's okay what I did
this is essentially killing the g7
bishop
it's just biting and grinded yeah this
is just another pawn basically and the
pin is not dangerous
then at the end the porn is promoting
and this opening variation here actually
with this early three is disgusting this
III poisoned book by excellent Smith um
it's a bit of him
this book is a little bit unorganized
but full of interesting ideas I think I
reviewed it on the channel while ago
yeah I hope you enjoyed the video thanks
for watching